I wonder if there's a question about swollen lip nodes. I have breast cancer and the nodes
under my arm are very sore. Is DMSO something to use to bring relief, or is there something
else that could help? Like I said, DMSO, Dysulf, Dysulf, that oxide is a sulfur component. You
could buy DMSO. It's liquid, it's like water. You just use a little bit on a cotton swab and it's
highly anti-inflammatory. Now it's a sulfur component, so you'll taste garlic in your
mouth after putting it on your skin. But it was very common in the 70s and 80s to use it on your,
or like a swollen knee, or a sore ankle, or a rheumatoid arthritis, any type of joy-darts
arthritis. And it kind of fell out of sorts because the FDA, what after it all, and said
it was a hoax and all this kind of stuff. But it isn't anti-inflammatory, you can't argue
with it. But it is also readily absorbed through the skin and it could be a driver. So if you
have lotion on your skin that's toxic and you put DMSO on it, it'll drive the toxic lotion
right into your body. You shouldn't be putting toxic lotion on your skin as the lesson. But so you've
got to be careful with it. If you have dirt on your skin or if you have gasoline on your skin
and you put DMSO on, you're literally driving the gasoline and it's toxic, petroleum toxins
right into your bloodstream. So you have to be careful what you use it over. But if you have
clean skin, putting a cotton, using a clean organic cotton swab in the bottle of DMSO and putting
it right on it, test it, see how it works. It could be a great anti-inflammatory. You could also use
it to drive other things. So you could get a liquid zinc, put that on the skin and then put
DMSO over it just like that. If you're putting a putting them, that's why some of the blood root
pastes have DMSO on it because it will drive the blood root in through the skin. So you can use it
as a driver of other things too.